ce qui fait de la rose ni université
d'été les socialistes du rhône étaient
conviés à un séminaire de rentrée
invité vedette bertrand delanoë un
invité quelque peu éclipsé par le débat
autour de la constitution européenne
sylvia dans alain qu ils devaient
débattre d'aménagement du territoire de
développement durable voire d'emplois
mais le référendum sur la question
européenne était dans tous les esprits
et la position de laurent fabius sur
toutes les langues
l odc nantes parce qu'elle fait appel
aux gouvernements de droite et qu' elle
ne l'est elle ne l'est finalement
entrevoir qu'une impasse c'est pas leur
enthousiasme
mais ce n'est pas non plus le défaitisme
commencé à expliquer qu'une constitution
qui est fait au niveau européen ça doit
être au président de la république
française de la modifier c'est un peu se
moquer du monde
pour le moment non sauf revirement du
texte mais en l'occurrence aujourd'hui
c'est non le problème c'est que j'ai pas
fini mon étude de la constitution m s'il
faut il nous conduit oui plutôt pour la
constitution pourra toujours l'améliorer
lui aussi favorable au oui bertrand
delanoë affirme son réformisme tout
progrès est bon à prendre
il ne faut pas faire la politique du
tout ou rien moi je suis moins idéaliste
que laurent c'est à dire que je
n'attends pas des gens de droite qui
fasse une politique de gauche mais il a
raison d'essayer je ne peux pas le
contredire en termes de raisonnement en
revanche n'a pas parlé du texte le
séminaire socialiste de 2004 a attiré
moins de monde que celui de 2003
certains l'expliqué par l'absence de
perspectives électorales
d'autre part le choix de l'invité
d'honneur l'an dernier c'était laurent
fabius
haguy